[Music]
what is up everybody its Anna Mack here
for anime uproar and chapter 98 of
attack on Titan has just become
available so as always I'm going to give
you my chapter review for this chapter
as usual I'm not gonna do a lot of heavy
editing for this video because I want to
get it out to you guys as soon as
possible as with any chapter review
there will be spoilers of course so if
you're not caught up to the manga
proceed with extreme caution
this was another crazy chapter we got a
lot of world-building
plot twists an epic face-to-face
showdown between two former friends and
current bitter enemies and potential
clues about a secret plan that Zeek
Jaeger aka the beast Titan may have just
put into motion in my kid Titans see the
future attack on Titan video I suggested
that with his impressive intelligence
there is no way that Zeke was so naive
as to think that everything would be
fine for the audience once they defeated
the Islanders and in that video I
speculated about Zeke possibly
formulating a secret plan to outmaneuver
Marlay officials in this chapter we
might have gotten some important low key
clues about that plan but I will break
that down a little bit later be sure to
leave a like if you enjoy these reviews
and want to see more in the future and
if you're new to the channel don't
forget to subscribe and hit that
notification bell chapter 98 starts off
with Reiner and the other warriors of
Marley discussing the plan to invade
Paradise Island together with Marlon
officials after the meeting when porco
makes her remark about the Marlin
officers being wise and him looking
forward to seeing what type of plan they
come up with Peake remarks like trusting
everything to four children
referring to Gabby Sophia judo and Falco
and this whole idea of entrusting
important missions and important
resources such as the shifter powers
to mere children is something that has
been bugging me for a while about Marlay
don't forget that they did the same
thing earlier with Marcel Reiner
Bertolt and Andy and I plan to talk
about this at greater length in a theory
video that I'm working on right now that
will involve any and Arbonne so stay
tuned for that
we then see Falco overtaking Gabby in
their training by sprinting faster than
her for the first time
Gabby looks upset of course but we know
that Falco is trying so hard because he
wants to save Gabby from having to
become the next armored Titan and he is
prepared to do whatever it takes to
inherit the power in her place not long
after when Gabby confronts Falco about
why he is trying so hard to inherit the
armored Titan when he knows that his
brother colt is already set to inherit
the beast Titan meaning that Falco's
family will be granted honorary Merlyn
status anyway
Falco loses his cool and tells Gabby
outright that he is doing it for her
sake I thought that has showed some
great character development and it also
clearly demonstrates that Falco is
thinking about what being a shifter
really means he is no longer brainwashed
by Marlin propaganda we then see
preparations being made for the big
festival where the declaration of war
against parodies will be made
we learned that guests from other
countries will be present at the event
including dignitaries from the East
Union with whom our lay was at war less
than a month ago apparently the goal is
for people from all around the world to
come and see for themselves that the LD
ends in Marlay are not Devils like the
LD ins on parodies and so they are being
invited to witness the Marlin LD ends
declaring war on the Islanders at this
point
judo reveals that his family is
originally from another country and that
outside of Marlay LD ins are treated
even worse venom Marlay and this is just
insane and so hard to even imagine
knowing how discriminated the LD ends
are in marl a once again this hints at
the fact that if Titan power becomes
obsolete in the near future
LD ins will be in serious danger as it
seems that most of the world wants to
exterminate them we then jump to Willy
Tiber previously translated as Billy
Tiber but apparently
is the proper translation and he is
having a conversation with commander
Maga
we learned that this is all taking place
about one month after Willy and Magath
first met and Willy is now wearing what
looks like a badass fedora and he is
entrusted command of the military of
Marlay to Maga Willy says that he holds
the steering wheel of Marley but he
doesn't want to do it because it is too
heavy of a burden and this makes me
think what is Willy's plan if he doesn't
want to rule over Marley from the
shadows then how is he planning to
change that situation in the next scene
falco is shown talking to mr. Kruger
again on the hospital grounds
we learned that Falco has been passing
multiple letters between mr. Kruger and
his so-called family and Kruger tells
Falco that after the festival he will be
going back to his hometown this of
course reminds me of how Reiner and
Berthold kept talking about going back
to their hometown while they were on
parodies as Falco leaves mr. Kruger who
was obviously Aaron is approached by
none other than dr. jaegar grisha's
father and Aaron's grandfather dr.
jaegar tells Aaron that Falco's uncle
was a member of the LDN restorationist
s' and that in order to save their
family from being implicated in treason
Colt and Falco decided to dedicate
themselves to becoming warriors dr.
jaegar then begins to tell Aaron about
the regrets he has about his own family
and what he means of course is what
happened first to crush a sister and
then to Grisha and dr. jaegar then
begins to scream uncontrollably and in a
crazy twist we realized that dr. jaegar
is not a doctor at the hospital but
rather one of its patients driven to
madness by what happened to his children
in the scene after that we see a party
presumably the elite citizens of Marley
and dignitaries from other countries are
gathered here and the four child
Warriors are acting as servants for them
judo accidentally spills wine on a woman
who is wearing a traditional Japanese
kimono and rather than get angry she
pretends that she spilled it on her
selves so that you don't get in trouble
the kids are all surprised that instead
of hating him for being LD end the Asian
woman actually protected him
they say that she must be from his ool
which is presumably the name of her
country in Asia and by showing us this
woman clearly Yama is telling us that
while inside the walls on parodies the
so-called Asian clan is nearly extinct
clearly in the outside world that is not
the case
Willy then gives a speech where he
explains that he has found a solution
for ending the cycle of death and
violence that the power of the Titans
has brought upon the world and he says
that he will reveal this plan the next
day the following day a whole bunch of
outsiders pour into libero internment
zone and the festival begins during the
festival falco leads Reiner into an
underground chamber that is hidden away
from the public and there Reiner comes
face to face with the so-called mr.
krüger eren yeager aaron tells him that
he is glad that ryder was able to return
to his hometown and that's where the
chapter ends and there you have it for
all those people who kept asking why I
was saying that this was definitely
Aaron infiltrating Marley and that there
was no evidence that it's really him it
is now confirmed that it was Aaron all
along because Reiner clearly recognized
him straight away this was a crazy
encounter between two old friends and
current enemies and I really wonder what
will happen next I also feel like this
chapter might be giving us some
important clues about Zeke's secret plan
we see Zeke playing catch with a
baseball in one scene in this chapter
and we also see that Aaron has a
baseball and the baseball glove with him
in another seat is this a clue that
Aaron and Zeke may be secretly
communicating Aaron did say that he was
sending letters to his family but I'd
assumed that that meant Mikasa Armin and
the others however what if he was
sending letters back and forth to his
literal family his half-brother Zeke
some of you guys suggested this in the
comments to the last chapter of you but
I personally didn't
this would be the case since Zeke and
Aaron are technically enemies and I
didn't think Aaron would risk blowing
his cover by contacting Zeke but when we
take into consideration that in the last
chapter it appeared as if Zeke was
possibly listening in on the
conversation between McGough and Willy
Tiber the same conversation in which
Willy admitted that the Thai burrs are
secretly in control of Marley and if we
combine that with the fact that Zeke
encourages Reiner to follow falco to the
room where Aaron was hiding by
essentially saying it's fine there's
still some time before the curtain rises
and it starts to look like Zeke is
secretly working behind the backs of the
timers and maybe trying to unite the
forces of the audience on parodies with
the Warriors of Marley to potentially
take down the tiber family maybe Zeke
was the one who made sure that Aaron and
Reiner meet because he wants them to
join forces and take on the Tigers
together that would be a crazy twist but
I have to say we are used to crazy
twists by now the reveal from last
chapter that the tiber secretly control
Marley totally shocked me and now the
prospect of Reiner
Eden Arman Mekas Oliva and Zeke all
potentially coming together against the
common enemy sounds really intriguing to
me
maybe Aaron during his stay in Marley
realized that the ldiots here are
suffering he realized why Rainer did
what he did
and now he wants to make things right by
eliminating the forces that are
responsible for all of their suffering
in the first place
if the warriors joined forces with Aaron
and Arman we will have seven Titan
shifter powers facing off the Warhammer
Titan with Annies female Titan being the
only missing one I don't know if this
will really happen but I have to say
that this was another fantastic chapter
and along with the rapidly advancing
plot I also really enjoyed the world
building as we were introduced to
characters from other countries be sure
to tell me what you think did you like
the chapter what do you think is going
to happen between Aaron and Reiner will
they fight each other or make peace and
what about Zeke are we witnessing
secret master plan that he created
coming together let me know down below
if you enjoyed this video be sure to
leave a like to let me know and if
you're new to the channel don't forget
to subscribe and hit that notification
bell honestly the only bad thing about
this chapter which had such an amazing
ending is that we now have to wait for a
month to figure out what happens next
but overall I really loved it as always
thank you so much for watching and until
next time see our space cowboys
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]